WHAT OKAY OKAY. OKAY LET ME GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES ARE TO ORDER
SO GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I
WILL BE MAKING SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES THAT WE HAVE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE TUNING IN FOR THE
FIRST TIME. SAW COVER THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY IN RESPONSE TO THE COBIT
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
WE HAVE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. WERE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR BATES
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
REMOTELY WITH THE USE OF VIDEO
CONFERENCE SYSTEM. I
ADDITIONALLY I WOULD ADD THE
SENATOR BATES BY NOW IS QUITE
FAMILIAR WITH MANY OF OURNEW
TECHNOLOGY SO I KNOW THAT SHE'S
PREPARED AND READY TO GO. AND
WITH THAT LET ME ASK YOU
SENATOR BATES IF SHE WOULD
PLEASE IDENTIFY ANYONE THAT IS
IN THE ROOM WITH HER. AT THIS
TIME. YES GOOD AFTERNOON AND WE
NEED TO BE AS RESPECT AND MINE
THAT COULD BE RECESSED. THANK
YOU SENATOR SO ARE BACK TO OUR
HEARING PROCESS I TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFIED TODAY REMOTELY FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT'S GOING TO BE
DISPLAYED ON OUR SCREEN RIGHT
NOW. AND THAT PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS. NINE TWO FOUR
ONE FOUR FIVE EIGHT ARE YOU CAN
SEE IT UP THERE AND WILL REPEAT
THAT THROUGHOUT THE HEARING-
FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. WHEN WE
DO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND I
WILL REPEAT THIS AS WELL- OR AT
LEAST PART OF IT A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY.
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ANY FEEDBACK. YOU HAVE TO
MUTE THE DEVICE THAT YOU ARE
WATCHING THIS HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT WILL CAUSE
PROBLEMS IF YOU DON'T DO IT IN
THAT WAY AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR YOU- AND WE AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL REMAIN- I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE.
MAYBE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS. SO AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE SO THAT EVERYONE
CAN BE HEARD. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY ON BEHALF OF OUR
INCREDIBLY HARDWORKING
STENOGRAPHER. I WANT TO ASK ALL
SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES IN
WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. AND IF NEED BE I
WILL INTERRUPT- ONLY TO ASK YOU
TO SLOW DOWN- SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR YOUR TESTIMONY. AND THE
STENOGRAPHER WILL BE ABLE TO
GET IT ALL DOWN. SO MADAM
SECRETARY WITH THAT LET ME ASK
YOU TO CALL THE ROLL. PLEASE
TURN YOUR MICROPHONES. THEY
FEAR BATES HERE. BURKE HERE FOR
HERE AIRED HERE HERE HERE WILK
PRESIDENT WILL PRESENT ATKINS
HERE ATKINS HERE AND THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY I WAS SUPPOSED
TO REMIND PEOPLE TO TURN ON
THEIR MICROPHONES I APPRECIATE
THE ASSIST- WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO DO IS LOOK AT OUR OUR-
AGENDA FOR TODAY. AND ASK MY
COLLEAGUES AND I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD MADAM SECRETARY POLL ALSO
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEM TWO. I
ITEM G. N. H. R. BRIAN CHOI N.
R. I'M SORRY. HI ERIN CHOI SEE
YOU'RE ALREADY HAVING THAT
YEAH- TO HELP ME HERE- ERIN
CHOI MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
EXPOSITION AND STATE FAIR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS AS WELL AS ITEM H.
BRIAN MAY ALSO MEMBER
CALIFORNIA EXPOSITION STATE
FAIR BOARD OF DIRECTORS. I SEE
MY WAY TO WORK MAKING A MOTION
FEED ONE THANK YOU- MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE OLL ON
ITEM TWO G. AND H. EIGHTH. I. I
HERTZBERG PIE BURKE I LAYERED
HI THERE I WILL I WILL I ATKINS
AYE ATKINS AYE FIVE FIVE TWO
ZERO THANK YOU. I'M I'M GONNA
ASKING GO AHEAD AND SEE IF WE
COULD TAKE UP ITEM THREE BILL
REFERRALS TO COMMITTEE AND
ACTUALLY ITEM FOR COMMITTEE
SCHEDULE. THE MOTION ON THAT
THE MOVE THANK YOU MR MAJORITY
LEADER- SEEING NOTHING FURTHER
WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL MADAM
SECRETARY FAITH I IT'S AYE
HERTZBERG AYE. HI THERE HI
YEARS BY I. HI CAN FIVE ATKINS
I THANK YOU. FIVE ZERO. SO NOW
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR WE'RE GONNA START
WITH ITEM ONE A. AND THAT WOULD
BE MISTER DOUGLAS ARE MCCAULEY
REAL ESTATE COMMISSIONER AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE SO
LET ME GO AHEAD AND SAY WELCOME
TO YOU- COMMISSIONER MACAULEY
AND ASK THAT IF YOU WANT TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE WITH YOU
TODAY- ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE AND
MAKE OPENING COMMENTS. A. N.
THE ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO SAY
AND THEN I WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
MY COLLEAGUES FOR ALSO THEIR
COMMENTS AND ANY QUESTIONS THEY
MIGHT HAVE ODD COMMISSIONER
CAULEY. WELCOME WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME TODAY- SHAPE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRO THOMAS ARE ATKINS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I ENJOY
THE CONVERSATIONS I WAS ABLE TO
HAVE. YESTERDAY SO I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT ABOUT SEVENTY TWO MY
WIFE LISA. AND MY SON'S DONE
JUNIOR JAMES WITH ME TODAY AND
I'M PLEASED TO HAVE THEIR- LOVE
AND SUPPORT THROUGHOUT MY
PUBLIC SERVICE CAREER. I'M
HONORED TO SERVICE REAL ESTATE
COMMISSIONER DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. HOUSING AND
REAL ESTATE TRANSACTIONS ARE
STILL CRUCIAL TO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. AND LIVABILITY
ESPECIALLY WITH SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLING I'M
GRATEFUL AND HUMBLE THE
GOVERNOR TO SOME SELECTED ME TO
SERVE IN THIS IMPORTANT ROLE.
DURING THIS IMPORTANT TIME. BY
EXPERIENCE IN REAL ESTATE AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION MAKES ME
UNIQUELY QUALIFIED TO SERVE AS
COMMISSIONER. ONCE I WAS
APPOINTED IN APRIL I WORK
DILIGENTLY WITH OUR EXECUTIVE
TEAM TO RAPIDLY DEPLOY HE
EQUIPMENT TRAINING AND
RESOURCES OUR TEAM NEEDED TO
WORK SAFELY AND A REMOTE
SETTING. AND I'M PLEASED TO
SHARE THAT WE HAVE 90% OF OUR
TEAM AND DO YOUR READ. ON THE
TELEWORK SCHEDULE. OUR MOST
PUBLIC FACING COMPONENT THAT'S
BEEN AFFECTED BY CO IT IS OUR
LICENSING EXAM AS YOU MIGHT
EXPECT. AND DESPITE THE STATE
HOME ORDERS THAT REQUIRED US TO
SHUT DOWN FOR ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS. AS WELL AS THE NEED TO
WORK AT 50% CAPACITY TO
MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS. WE'VE
ACTUALLY MINISTER MORE EXAMS
DURING THIS PERIOD THAN WE DID
LAST YEAR AT THIS TIME AND
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT
ACCOMPLISHMENT. WE'VE DONE
SERVICE SO THREE VERY
AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULING AS WELL
AS ADDING CAPACITY VIA EVENING.
AND SATURDAY EXAMINATIONS AND
ALL THIS WORK TRANSLATES TO
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
EARNING THEIR LICENSE ENTERING
THE ORK FORCE AND WORKING IN
AN EXCITING FIELD. OF REAL
ESTATE. WE'VE ALSO REDOUBLE OUR
EFFORTS TO GO AFTER UNLICENSED
PRACTICE ILLEGAL OPERATORS ARE
ABSOLUTELY OUT THERE IN THE
MARKETPLACE. AND WHEN YOU THINK
OF A REAL ESTATE TRANSACTION.
AVERAGE CONSUMER FOR MOST
CONSUMERS IT'S GOING TO BE THE
MOST IGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT YOU MAKE IN YOUR
LIFE. AND THAT ABSOLUTELY
ATTRACTS ABOUT ACTORS SO IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. THAT GEE
ARE YOU BE VIGILANT AND
AGGRESSIVE AND STEP INTO THE
MARKET PLACE TO ENSURE THAT
CONSUMERS. ARE PROTECTED. AS
COMMISSIONER MY COMMITMENT TO
YOU IS TO BE TRANSPARENT
COLLABORATIVE AND INNOVATIVE I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. TO FIND
NEW AND BETTER WAYS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AS WE STRIVE TOWARD
GOVERNOR NEWSON GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S VISION. OF A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER. I APPRECIATE
THAT. LET ME GO AHEAD AND GO
FIRST TO SENATOR BATES WHO'S
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. SENATOR
BATES. BUT I THINK YOU- YEAH
OUR CONGRATULATIONS
COMMISSIONER MACAULEY FOR ON
YOUR NOMINATION I WOULD LIKE TO
START OUT BY APPRECIATING THE
LITTER THEY CHEW SANCHIN
RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT CAME FORWARD I
THINK WAS MANAGE TWENTY TWENTY
LAST YEAR BUT I THOUGHT YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT WAS VERY
THOROUGH- I AM CERTAINLY I
ANSWERED EVERY ONE OF THE OB. I
GUESS HE CALLED THE ALLEGATIONS
REGARDING YOUR QUALIFICATIONS
TO SERVE IN THIS POSITION SO I
AM CONVINCED THAT YOU CERTAINLY
NEED THE STANDARD BY AND JOB
AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS FOR ARE
BEING SELECTED BY OUR GOVERNOR
TO TAKE THIS VERY IMPORTANT
POSITION I DO HAVE YOU ANSWERED
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAD
IN MIND REGARDING THE
TIMELINESS OF. THE OUR
LICENSING AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
WHATEVER IT TOOK PLACE THERE ON
ON THE HOME FRONT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE APPLYING FOR
LICENSURE ON THEY GOT A TIMELY
RESPONSE TO THAT AND I AM SURE
THAT TOOK A LOT OF WORK WHEN
WE'VE BEEN ALL KIND OF
HANDICAPPED WITH THE COLUMBIA.
AND WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO
ADMINISTRATIVELY DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION IT'S REGARDING THE-
THE INVESTIGATIONS ARE. WHEN
YOU DO A- I'LL- WHEN SOMEONE
FILES A HOW YOU UP THEIR ON THE
DESK THE TRACKING OF THAT RIGHT
NOW WHERE IT'S AND YOU CAN THEM
NO- WITH- YOU'RE INVESTING AND
THEN THE- AND I KINDA THE
TIMELINE ON ALL OF THE WOULD BE
HOW BE AT THE WHERE WE DO.
RECEIVE ANOTHER OF THOSE AND
JOB ALWAYS DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO REACH AND SHE THE AGENCY
ITSELF AND TRY TO GET
INFORMATION UNLESS YOU HAVE
SOME WAY THAT YOU'RE POSTING
THAT ARE KEEPING THEM INFORMED
SO YOU'LL CLICK ON OVERVIEW FOR
US ON HOW THAT WORKS WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR US AT THE DISTRICT
LEVEL. CERTAINLY SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST AS A CONSUMER
PROTECTION AGENCY WE DO
INVESTIGATE ANY AND ALL
COMPLAINTS WE RECEIVE M. IT IS
OUR REQUIREMENTTHAT OUR
INVESTIGATORS TO KEEP
COMPLAINTS UP TO DATE ON A
REGULAR BASIS. I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LISTEN TO THE
DIALOGUE- REGARDING THE MEDICAL
BOARD LAST WEEK AND IT DID GIVE
ME A FEW IDEAS- WE DO NEED TO
FORMALIZE THIS PROCESS AND
PROVIDE SOME APPROPRIATE
STRUCTURE SO THAT WERE INSURING
THAT COMPLAINTS ARE INDEED UP
THE DAHLE FREQUENT. REGULAR
BASIS BECAUSE THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. GET WORKING FOR THAT
YEAH- YOU ANSWERED MOST OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT I HAD IN MIND
IN YOUR PRESENTATION SO
APPRECIATE THAT. YEAH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CENTER
GLARED YOU WANNA. GO NEXT YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR. OF A AND- ALSO
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR- YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND THEN I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR OF FOR MEETING
WITH ME YESTERDAY I REALLY
APPRECIATED. AND YOU ANSWERED
MOST OF MY QUESTIONS BUT
THERE'S ONE I'D LIKE TO DRAW
YOU OUT A LITTLE ONE AND THAT
IS UNLICENSED ACTIVITY WE
TALKED ABOUT IT YESTERDAY
ABOUT. HOW YOU DEAL WITH IT I
THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE GOOD IF IN
GENERAL YOU EXPLAIN. WHAT THE
ACTIONS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
TAKES TO GET OUT ON LICENSED
ACTIVITY AND THEN I WANT TO ASK
YOU ABOUT- THE PENALTIES AND
WHETHER YOU HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO DO IT ONCE YOU GET
THROUGH- JUST A BRIEF
INTRODUCTION OF THE SUBJECT.
SURE THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SO OUR APPROACH ON UNLICENSED
PRACTICE IS MULTI DIMENSIONAL
WHAT'S A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
AND YOU HAVE TO RELY ON- AS
MANY MODES AS POSSIBLE TO GET
AT THE PROBLEM AND FIND ABOUT
ACTORS SO WE DO SEVERAL THINGS
ONE. WE HAVE A CADRE OF STAFF
WHO POLICE THE VARIOUS ONLINE
PRESENCES FOR THE BAD ACTORS
TEND TO POP UP WE ACTUALLY
INCREASED THE AMOUNT OF TIME.
THEY'RE DEVOTING TO THIS EFFORT
EVERY TIME WE DO AN
INVESTIGATION AND WE TALKED TO-
THE ACTUAL LICENSEES A VERY
SCENARIOS WE ASK THEM WHAT'S
GOING ON IN YOUR MARKETPLACE
OTHER OTHER FOLKS WE NEED TO BE
AWARE OF. WE DO THE SAME THING
WHEN WE CONDUCT OUR AUDITS
ADDITIONALLY ARE FORSMAN STAFF
REACH OUT REGULARLY TO THE
LOCAL ASSOCIATIONS OF REALTORS.
AND ASK THEM ABOUT CURRENT
TRENDS IN THE MARKET PLACE AND
WHAT'S WHAT'S TAKING PLACE. IN
THIS WORLD THAT WE NEED TO BE
AWARE OF SO IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT- FUNCTION FOR US AND
WE NEED TO TACKLE IT THROUGH AS
MANY MEANS AS POSSIBLE. AND DO
YOU FEEL YOU HAVE ENOUGH STAFF
RESOURCES TO GET AT THE LEVEL
OF UNLICENSED ACTIVITY THAT
YOU'RE SEEING. TWO POINTS ONE.
WE HAVE SUFFICIENTLY FORCE
RESOURCES IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
METRICS WE PERFORMED A VERY
HIGH LEVEL AND MEET OUR
STANDARDS WITH RESPECT TO HOW
LONG IT TAKES US TO. ADJUDICATE
COMPLAINTS WITH RESPECT TO THE
SPECIFIC RESOURCES FOR
UNLICENSED PRACTICE DIRECTLY
YOU COULD NEVER HAVE ENOUGH- I
THINK WE DO A VERY GOOD JOB
WITH THE RESOURCES WE HAVE. WE
WOULD CERTAINLY TAKE MORE DOWN
THE ROAD I'M HAPPY TO LOOK AT
WHAT THAT MIGHT LOOK LIKE AND
CIRCLE BACK TO YOU SO THE
PERHAPS THERE'S SOMETHING WE
CAN WORK ON THROUGH. THE BUDGET
PROCESS POTENTIALLY. AND DID I
UNDERSTAND- YESTERDAY FROM OUR
MEETING THAT THE FINES THAT ARE
COLLECTED. AND I THINK IT MAXES
OUT AT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED OR
SOMETHING DID I UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY DO NOT COME TO YOU. SO
THERE'S NOT THIS FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE FOR YOU. TO GO AFTER
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY IS THAT
CORRECT. LET ME CLARIFY- I NEED
TO VERIFY WHETHER FISCAL STAFF
BUT IT'S BEEN MY UNDERSTANDING
TRADITIONALLY WITH LICENSING
BOARDS THAT- THE PENALTIES THE
MONETARY PENALTIES ARE INDEED
DEPOSITED AND ARE FUND I THINK
THE POINT I WAS TRYING TO
ARTICULATE. AND I APOLOGIZE IF
I WASN'T CLEAR- WAS SIMPLY THAT
CITATIONS AND THE PENALTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM. ARE
REALLY NOT A COST RECOVERY
MECHANISM SO WE CAN HAVE A
CITATION AGAINST UNLICENSED
INDIVIDUAL. WITH A FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR PENALTY AND OUR OUR
COSTS MORE ALL IN MIGHT BE.
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN THAT SO
THEY'RE JUST. THEY'RE DESIGNED
TO BE A PENALTY AND IMPACTFUL
BUT NOT NECESSARILY TO RECOVER
FULL COVERAGE WOULD TODAY HAVE
REALIZED ANY REVENUE FROM A
FALL SALE. OF IN A WAY THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY MAKING MORE%
MONEY THAN THE COST OF THE
PENALTY FOR YOU JUST DEALING
WITH THEM ON ON THE LICENSED
WITHOUT THEM ACTUALLY HAVING
ENGAGED IN A TRANSACTION. WE'RE
WE'RE DEALING ON THE ON THE ON
LICENSE THE OTHER REALM WHERE
THAT WOULD BE ADDRESSABLE
CRIMINAL OR CIVIL. AND THEN-
LASTLY DO YOU THINK THE LEVEL
OF THE PENALTY IS INADEQUATE A
DETERRENT YOU'RE NOT SEEING
SOMEBODY COME BACK AROUND
BECAUSE THE PENALTY ISN'T
ENOUGH TO REALLY DO ANYTHING
BUT PASSED AWAY IN ONE
SITUATION. THE CENTER I THINK
YOU COULD MAKE THE CASE THAT
THE NUMBER COULD POTENTIALLY.
BE HIGHER BUT THERE'S A COFFEE
GUY IT'S TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS BUT IT'S TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER ACCOUNT SO
IF I HAVE AN UNLICENSED. PERSON
WHO DOES FIVE DONE DUMB
UNSEEMLY THINGS WE CAN BRING
THEM UP FOR FIVE CITATIONS AT.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED HOWEVER IF
YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE IT
WAS A SINGULAR COUNT THEN YOU
MIGHT WANT SOMETHING MORE
IMPACTFUL THAN TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. AND THEN THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN IS
ACTUALLY COLLECTING IT BECAUSE
THESE ARE LEGAL OPERATORS SO
THEY'RE GONNA. CLAIM
UNDERGROUND MAY BE DIFFICULT TO
FIND WE DO HAVE SOME TOOLS WE
HAVE A COLLECTION AGENCIES WE
HAVE. THE INTERCEPTOR OF RAM-
WITH THE TAX AGENCIES BUT IT
CERTAINLY COULD BE SOMETHING TO
LOOK AT WIH RESPECT TO THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT. IT WAS SET AT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
SOMETIME AGO I WOULD I WOULD
ESTIMATE OVER TEN YEARS AGO.
THANK YOU THIS BEEN REALLY
HELPFUL AND IF YOU IT DO THINK
THAT THERE'S AN APPROPRIATE WHY
THAT. THAT SOMETHING NEEDS TO
BE DONE FEEL FREE TO CIRCLE
BACK THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR POP MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM COULD AGAIN- COMMISSIONER
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT- ACTUALLY- CENTER
LAYERED ASK QUESTION I WAS MOST
INTERESTED IN- BUT LOOKING AT
THE D. R. E. COSTS AND
INCREASED SUBSTANTIALLY IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE YEAR AFTER
THE RE ESTABLISHMENT OF- D. R.
E. SO IS THERE A PARTICULAR
REASON WHY EIGHT THOSE COSTS
ARE NOTABLE AND ARE THERE IT
AND IF THERE ISN'T A PROBLEM IS
OUR WAY TO ADDRESS IT. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- I AYE
CENTER RIGHT I CAN'T DO WE NEED
TO VERIFY WITH OUR FISCAL STAFF
WHAT MAY HAVE DRIVEN THAT I
SUSPECT A PIECE OF IT IS SIMPLY
RETURNING BACK TO. DEPARTMENTAL
STATUS THERE WAS SOME LEVEL OF
TRADE OFF- I WOULD ASSUME
BETWEEN THE PRO RATA HE TO DCA
AND THEN ALSO INCURRING THE
COSTS DIRECTLY BUT I WOULD NEED
TO FACT CHECK UP. OR YOU. RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU MR
MAJORITY LEADER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I JUST WANT TO RAISE TWO
POINTS THAT WE RAISED IN OUR
CONVERSATION PRIOR TO THIS
HEARING. ON FIRST WE'LL AT THE
END OF LAST YEAR'S I SUGGESTED
TO YOU THE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR ON THE PAST LET IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED LEGISLATION
DEALING WITH THE ARE- FINANCIAL
DISTRESS WORD LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS- AS A RESULT YOU
PREPARE YOUR OFFICE PREPARED
THE DECLARATION FORM OF COVERT
NINETEEN FINANCIAL DISTRESS I
HAD OURS TAKE A STAFF OF TAKE A
LOOK AT THE COPIES OF WHAT YOU
PREPARED AND I FOUND HIM TO BE.
ON PASSABLE IN THE SENSE THAT.
AND I HEARD THIS SUBSEQUENTLY
IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU'RE STAFF
SAID WELL THIS IS WHAT THE
LEGISLATION SAID BUT WITHOUT
REALLY ADDRESSING ANY LEVEL OF
SENSITIVITY IS TO THE AUDIENCES
WE IN THE LEGISLATURE DRAFT
LAWS BUT- THOSE DID YOU NEED TO
PUT THOSE PROVISIONS OF COURSE
IN THE DOCUMENT. BUT YOU JUST
THREW IT TOGETHER WITH NO SENSE
OF CUSTOMER WHO YOUR CUSTOMER
WAS WITH THE AGENCY DOES WITH
ANY LEVEL OF SENSITIVITY AND I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND
EXPRESS THAT TO YOU BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
DISTRESS AND YOU NEED TO MAKE
DOCUMENTS EASY TO READ
ACCESSIBLE YES YOU NEED TO HAVE
THE PROVISIONS OF THE STATUTE
HAS BUT THERE'S CERTAINLY
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO IS A
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE IT EASIER.
ON THE FOLKS THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO THIS RATHER THAN JUST TO
HAND THEM SOME DOCUMENT DIDN'T
EVEN HAVE YOUR LOGO ON IT
DIDN'T HAVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LOGO ON IT. JUST
KIND OF SLOPPY TOGETHER NINE I
FELT THAT THAT WAS SOMEWHAT
CHALLENGING AND WE JUST THINK
THAT IN ALL OF THESE THINGS WE
DO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WE
INTERFACE WITH THE PUBLIC. WE
THINK ABOUT THEM WHEN THEY
THINK ABOUT THEIR CONDITIONS
AND THINK ABOUT WHAT IT'S LIKE
WHEN THEY GET A DOCUMENT FOR A
PIECE OF PAPER FROM THE
GOVERNMENT. AND MAKE IT IS EASY
AND SIMPLE ON THEM AS POSSIBLE
AND GO THE EXTRA DISTANCE
BEYOND JUST THE MINIMALIST
APPROACH WHICH WAS DONE IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOU DID IT
PARTICULARLY HOW SENSITIVE THE
SITUATION IS FOR THESE FOLKS I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT ON
THE RECORD. IS THINK IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
TAKE THE TIME AND DO THAT THE
SECOND THING. WAS THE WAIT
TIMES FOR PEOPLE WHEN THEY CALL
AGAIN. PEOPLE ARE COMING IN
THEY'VE GOT A PROBLEM THEY'RE
DISTRESSED YOU GOT TWENTY FIVE
TO THIRTY MINUTE WAIT TIMES NOW
I UNDERSTAND. THAT THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST OF OTHER FACTORS BUT
TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU CAN. TRY
TO- PUT SOME. ELBOW GREASE INTO
THOSE THINGS AGAIN TO TRY TO
PROVIDE. WHEN FOLKS ARE
COMPLAINING OF THEY'VE GOT A
PROBLEM. THE LICENSE HERE
WHATEVER. YOU WANT YOUR
GOVERNMENT TO BE AS AVAILABLE
AND IS RESPONSIVE AND AS
RESPECTFUL AS POSSIBLE. AND I
JUST THINK TO THE EXTENT YOU
CAN WORK ON THOSE THINGS THAT
WOULD TO THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
SUPPORTING YOU TODAY BUT I
JUST. WANT TO SHARE THOSE THOSE
TWO ISSUES ON THE RECORD
BECAUSE OF THE GUESTLIST. SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE EXPRESS THAT
LEVEL OF SENSITIVITY TO ALL WHO
INTERFACE THEIR GOVERNMENT. AND
MAKE IT THE MOST POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE POSSIBLE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I'M COMMISSIONER DID
YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT-
THAT'S THE LAST QUESTION BEFORE
I GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT JUST IN
CASE YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO. MR
HERTZBERG OF PLEASE DO. NOT
JUST JUST BRIEFLY- I ENDORSE
BOTH OF THOSE COMMENTS I'M
FIRMLY COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE SPIRIT OF THOSE
COMMENTS AND FINDING WAYS TO
IMPROVE- WITH RESPECT TO THE
DOCUMENTS I'VE ACTUALLY
EXPANDED OUR COMMUNICATIONS
SHOP HERE AND SO ONE OF OUR-
INITIAL TASKS FOR THEM IS TO
ACTUALLY REVIEW ALL OF OUR
CONSUMER MATERIAL AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S USABLE AND CURRENTS
AND- EFFECTIVE- AND THAT'S
DOUBLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
HOUSING IS KEY INFORMATION-
PARTICULARS TO THE- THE
DECLARATION- ESTHER CALL WAIT
TIMES YES ARE YOU. I WAS
DISAPPOINTED TO LEARN THE
NUMBERS WHEN I LANDED WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS WERE
ADDRESSING THEM ONE IS. THROUGH
OUR EXPANDED KEY LICENSING
SYSTEM WHICH ALL OUR CONSUMERS
TO PROCESS THEIR TRANSACTIONS
ONLINE SOME OF THAT'S AVAILABLE
NOW WE'RE ADDING THE REST OF
THE EQUATION. AND THEN SECONDLY
ON FROM I'M NOT HERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR NECESSARILY BUT WE
DO HAVE A PENDING B. C. P. THAT
WAS HEARD- IN THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE LAST WEEK ABOUT
WILL BE MOVING FORWARD TO YOU
AS WELL. THE ACQUISITION STORE
INFORMATION CENTER SO WE CAN DO
BETTER AND MEET THE METRICS
WE'D LIKE TO ATTAIN. FOR OUR
RESPONSE TIMES ON CALLS. THANK
YOU I. WE ARE TO GO NOW TO-
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT. I'M GONNA START
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. TO SEE IF THERE'S
SOMEONE WHO'S TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. NOT SEEING ANYONE WE
WILL GO TO THE SECOND ROOM THAT
WE HAVE AND THAT IS ROOM ONE
TWELVE. OKAY SEEING NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WE ARE GOING TO
GO TO THE TELECONFERENCES FROM
RIGHT NOW. AND- LET ME ASK IF
THE MODERATOR IS STANDING BY.
ANYBODY THANK YOU MR MODERATOR-
LET ME ASK OUR FOR THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WE NEED YOU
TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT IF
ANY N. I. YOUR POSITION ON THE
APPOINTMENT AND AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF OUR STENOGRAPHER PLEASE
SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. I
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD OPEN THE LINES AND- IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO LET ME KNOW HOW
MANY CALLERS WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE I WOULD APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU GO AHEAD. WE HAVE
BALCONY THREE IN Q. EARLIER THE
DOMINICAN WISH TO QUEUE UP IN
SUPPORT IN A PRESS ONE ZERO- TO
GO FIRST TO LINE FOURTEEN. THE
FLAT. HI THIS IS MARK FIBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP AND WE ARE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH MISTER MACAULAY
HAS. SERVED ADMIRABLY ON OUR
BOARD FOR A NUMBER FOR A WHILE
AND- I ALSO WANT TO ADD
PERSONALLY BUT I WORKED UNDER
MR MCCAULEY AT THE DEPARTMENT
HOUSING COMMITTEE GOVERNMENT I
WAS VERY PROUD TO CONSIDER
MCCAULEY AND A FRIEND. AND WE
ARE THE CALIFORNIA THE
PARTNERSHIP IS IN FULL SUPPORT
OF MR COLLEGE CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WE GO TO LINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- I WOULD
DOWNEY WITH LAINE HANSON ZERO
LINCOLN DOWNEY- AND I WANT TO
SPEAK TO THIS BODY ASA FORMER
DIRECTOR OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
I HAD THE IMMENSE PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH- COMMISSIONER-
MCCAULEY- IN AND ONE THING
THAT- I HOPE WILL PLEASE THIS
BODY IS THAT HE IS A PROBLEM
SOLVER- AS YOU ALL OF YOU KNOW
THERE ARE MULTIPLE PROBLEMS AT.
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND ITS CONSTITUENT BODIES AND
HE IS ONE PERSON THAT I ENJOYED
WORKING WITH THINKING OUTSIDE
THE BOX AND SOLVING PROBLEMS
WITH THAT I SUPPORT IS- HIS
APPOINTMENT AND THINK THIS BODY
FOR ENTERTAINING IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WE LIKE TO GO TO MIND FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CENTER ATKINS THIS IS
JOHN ROSS IN COMMITTEE THIS IS
JOHN ROSS KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE MORTGAGE
BANKERS ASSOCIATION- I'VE KNOWN
COMMISSIONER MACAULEY NEST
FAMILY- SOCIALLY PER FIFTEEN
YEARS AND I'VE INTERACTED WITH-
COMMISSIONER MY COLLEAGUE
PROFESSIONALLY OVER THAT TIME
IS AN EXCELLENT CHOICE- TO FILL
THIS ROLE AND I- ON BEHALF OF
THE MORTGAGE BANKERS OPERABLE
SUPPORT FIRST CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
ROSS R. MISTER MODERATOR THAT
WAS THREE BUT ARE THERE ANY
OTHER CALLERS IN THE QUEUE OR
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. IF
THERE'S ONE MORE IN Q. THANK
YOU GO AHEAD NEXT WITNESS. ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
METAPROGRAMMING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS INCREASE WITH CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTER OF MR
MCCAULEY'S APPOINTMENT OF
WORKED WITH MR KOHLI OF THE
LAST TWO DECADES IN VARIOUS
CAPACITIES THAT ARCHITECTS
BOARDED IT CBO IN WORKING
CLOSELY AND CO DEVELOPMENT
ENERGY EFFICIENCY. ISSUES AND
MORE RECENTLY AT H. U. D. MORE
GREEN BUILDING STANDARDS SEVEN
DOLLARS THE VERY ACCEPTABLE FOR
YOU TO WORK WITH THEM BUT BY
PROFESSIONAL HAD OFFICE- IN
PERSON ONE AND A DEBT TO BE A
GREAT INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE HE
VOLUNTEERS TIME INDICATED
CODES. XRAY BOYS BASKETBALL
TEAM INCLUDING MY SON WHICH IS
NOT EASY AGE GROUP TO WORK
WITHOUT YES THE WONDERS ABOUT
ALLOWED- SUPPORTED SUPPORTIVE.
THANK VERY MUCH MR CREW I ANY
FURTHER WITNESS. HELLO THERE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU IN A FEW
MINUTES MISTER MODERATOR SO
HAVING HEARD FROM WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT LET ME MOVE TO ANYONE
THAT MIGHT BE IN OPPOSITION
WILL COME BACK INTO ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE ASKING FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION. AND SEEING NO ONE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
LET ME MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELFTH.
ON THE SCREEN SAYING NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE MISTER
MODERATOR LESS THAN A FEW
MINUTES WE'RE BACK WITH YOU FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION. MAYBE WE SHOULD
HAVE THE FINAL DECISION IN A
PRESS ONE AND THERE ARE AT THIS
TIME. AND MAYBE YOU CAN TELL ME
HOW MANY E. R. FOLKS MIGHT BE
IN THE QUEUE AND GO AHEAD MR
MODERATOR. BY THE TIME THE KNOW
WHO ARE PEOPLE EACH YEAR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE WE WILL TALK
WITH YOU IN A FEW MORE MINUTES
ARE. OK HAVING HEARD FROM.
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT- WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK
FOR DISCUSSION WITH THE MEMBERS
I WOULD MOVE THIS CONFIRMATION
THE SENATOR LAYERED THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR MOTION- IF NO
FURTHER COMMENTS ARE MADAM
SECRETARY- WE WILL WOULD YOU
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. EIGHTH.
BATES AYE OF MADAM CHAIRMAN I
DID HAVE A QUESTION AND ASK OR
COMMENT TO MAKE PLEASE EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT HUNDRED I YOU KNOW
WHAT MADAM OF SENATOR BATES AYE
PLEASE FORGIVE ME GO RIGHT
AHEAD WITH YOUR QUESTION-
COMMISSIONER OLLI MCCAULEY IS
STILL STANDING BY ALREADY GOT
INTERESTS BUT HE DID MENTION
AND I WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR THAT BUT THAT HE WAS GOING
TO WORK ON ON A RESPONSE FONG.
STRUCTURE FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
COMPLAINTS IN THE QUEUE SO WE
KIND OF KNOW AND I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE NOTED THAT
AND THAT MAYBE HE COULD PROVIDE
A SLIDING UPDATE AND YOU KNOW
LET'S SAY A COUPLE OF MONTHS
YOU KNOW GIVE A QUARTER- I'M
TRYING TO LINE FOR IT SO THAT
WE DO KNOW BECAUSE OUT OF THE
DISTRICT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SHARE THAT WITH ALL THOSE-
COMPLAINTS COME THROUGH OUR
OFFICE SEEMS LIKE THERE IS A
PROCESS AND YOU WILL BE
NOTIFIED. THE FEDERAL SO I
DON'T WANT TO PUT. THAT OUT
THERE AND SHE'LL SURE MACAULAY
HAS HIGH YOUR DRESS. FOR THOSE
FINAL SWITCHING THING BUT A
SEARCH SOMETHING THAT YOU FELT
NEXT. ALL HEY JUST. HAVE NOW ON
THE RECORD THANK YOU SO. I HOPE
ITS HIKES. MALCOLM MCCALL- ALL
DIRECT TO YOU OUR RULES
COMMITTEE WILL FOLLOW WITH
COURSE. ON THAT IF YOU A AGREE.
WHAT WILL UP WITH CORRESPONDING
BUT- NOTED AND IS THAT OKAY
WITH YOU WE CAN PROCEED WITH
THE VOTE. ABSOLUTELY PLEASE DO.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER- JUST
TOTALLY NOTED AND APPRECIATED
AND THAT THAT MAN SECRETARY.
SENATOR BATES IS AN I'D
CONTINUE THANK YOU WITH AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
LAYARD AYE LAYERED AYE WILK HI
LOOK I ATKINS HI CONCERNING
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER FIVE TWO
ZERO. CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. LET ME YA BEFORE
WE MOVE ON LET ME JUST DOUBLE
CHECK AND SEE IF OUR
STENOGRAPHER NEEDS OF A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK. THE NEXT WHICH
SHOULD BE A LITTLE LONGER. I'M
GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH MR BLOCKED OKAY SO WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE NEXT ITEM
AND THAT WOULD BE. OUT WE HAVE
ACTUALLY FIVE ARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMISSION ON POLICE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
OUR LAW ALLY- E. ARBURY DONLAN
ACTUALLY FORGIVE ME IT'S
SERGEANT- A SERGEANT I DONE
WHEN I MISTER JEFF LONG
SERGEANT JAMES O'ROURKE AND
SERGEANT BUT TíNH RAMIREZ I
WANT TO MAKE SURE I GIVE YOU
THE HONOR OF YOUR TITLE YOU'VE
CERTAINLY EARNED IT NOT JUST AS
COMMISSIONERS BUT AS OUR
MEMBERS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT SO.
WELCOME HI TO EACH OF YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I
THINK WHAT WE WILL DO IS TAKE
UP OUR INTRODUCTIONS IN THE
ORDER THAT I STATED- WHICH IS
THE ORDER OF THE AGENDA
BEGINNING WITH COMMISSIONER ABU
WE LITTLE AND THEN GO FORWARD
TO COMMISSIONER DUNLIN MISTER
LONG SERGEANT O'ROURKE-
SERGEANT RAMIREZ AND I EACH OF
YOU I FEEL FREE TO INTRODUCE-
ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU.
A KNOWLEDGE ANYONE MAKE YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS AND STATEMENTS
WILL GO DOWN THE LINE AND THEN
I WILL START WITH- SENATORS ON
THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS SO WITH
THAT LET ME TURN IT OVER TO
COMMISSIONER AND SERGEANT ABU
EIGHT LITTLE. WELCOME THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SENATORS-
I FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- WHOSE STAFF- I'VE-
WORKED WITH THEM SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE WHEN I WAS A
INITIALLY APPOINTED AND SO WE
HAVE A GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP- THERE ARE A GREAT
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO WORK VERY
VERY HARD- ON BEHALF OF- PEACE
OFFICERS ACROSS THE STATE. SO
JUST TO GIVE YOU- US A BRIEF
INFORMATION ABOUT MY
PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUND- I'VE
BEEN WITH SEVERAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT FOR TWENTY SIX YEARS
AS A PEACE OFFICER. I WORKED
PATROL FOR MANY YEARS- AND I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN PROBLEM
ORIENTED AND COMMUNITY ORIENTED
POLICING MY WHOLE CAREER. I
SPEAK UP TO. LANGUAGES IN
ADDITION TO ENGLISH IT'S A
CHINESE AND VIETNAMESE AND THAT
HAS- BEEN VALUED BY A VERY
VALUABLE TO ME SENSE- WE HAVE A
VERY DIVERSE. ASIAN COMMUNITY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. I SPENT
SEVERAL YEARS AS A TECH
DETECTIVE WHERE I INVESTIGATED
SEX ASSAULTS CHILD ABUSE
NARCOTICS AND VICE. AND THEN
FROM THERE- I WORKED IN THE
MORE CEREBRAL SIDE OF- POLICING
WHERE WE USE RESEARCH AND DATA.
ARE TO HELP US PRACTICE
INTELLIGENCE LED POLICING. I
WAS ALSO- IN INTERNAL AFFAIRS
FOR COUPLE YEARS WERE
INVESTIGATED INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL COMPLAINTS TO ENSURE
AN- EMPLOYEE ACCOUNTABILITY-
AND JUST RECENTLY NOW I'VE
BEEN- ASSIGNED TO THE BY TEAM
WHERE I WORK HERE IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO. YOU'VE PROBABLY
SEEN ME WRITER WRITING AROUND-
ON MY BIKE AROUND THE CAPITAL.
WELL THE LAST TWO YEARS. AND AS
I MENTIONED I SERVED ON THE
POST COMMISSION SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE REPRESENTING
LINED UP THE LINE LEVEL PERSON
OF PERSPECTIVE- AND THE YOU
DON'T. I WORK WITH POST STAFF
AND OUR FELLOW POLICE
COMMISSIONERS HERE FOR SINCE
THEN AND I THINK THAT WE'VE
ACHIEVED A LOT OF SUCCESS OVER
THE YEARS. LEAVE THAT MY WELL
ROUNDED EXPERIENCE MAKES ME A
VALUABLE ASSET TO THIS
COMMISSION- AND I THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND
I WOULD APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE. THANK YOU. FOR A
SERGEANT DONE LINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR SENATORS
AT FIRST WE JUST SAY TO MY
FAMILY OR WATCHING FROM HOME
DEPENDING ON SOON CLASSES
COURSES DR. DALLAS FOR OVER TWO
DECADES ISN'T POLICE OFFICER.
ANH THANK YOU TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN THAT I'VE PROUD TO SERVE
WITH ICE SERVICES BEEN VERY AND
START OUT TROLL DIVISION
TRAFFIC DIVISION. AND THAT
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS
DIVISION. DURING MY TERM AS
OPPOSED COMMISSIONER I
APPRECIATED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING AND SOME ON THE ON THE
GROUND EXPERIENCE TO MATTERS
UNDER DISCUSSION BY POLLS.
ROUTINELY I'M IMPRESSED WITH
THE QUALITY AND BREADTH OF
EXPERIENCE THAT'S ALMOST AS AN
ORGANIZATION PASS AND THE POST
COMMISSIONERS THEMSELVES BRING
TO OUR DISCUSSION ON STANDARDS
AND TRAINING FOR CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS. I AM PROUD TO
SERVE WITH MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS SEVERAL OF WHOM.
ARE HERE TODAY AND I AM
GRATIFIED BY HARD GROUPS
CONSISTENT AND DILIGENT EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE FOR FASHION. THANK
YOU TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR REAL
POINTING ME TO POST I'M
DELIGHTED TO CONTRIBUTE. ED
THROUGH CLOSE TO A LOCATION
THAT I ENTERED MANY YEARS AGO.
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING CONFIRMED
IN CONTINUING TO SERVE OUR
STATE I THANK YOU ALL. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I WILL GO
TO- JEFF LONG WELCOME GOOD SEE
YOU. I DON'T THINK WE CAN HEAR
YOU THERE **** YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOHN IT'S GOOD TO SEE
ALL OF YOUR SANDERS HERTZBERG
BAIRD BATES AND WELL. IT'S A
PLEASURE AND A PRIVILEGE TO BE
BACK IN THE SENATE BEFORE YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS JEFF LONG I
SERVED ON THE POST COMMISSION
FOR FIVE YEARS SINCE- TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. UPON MY
RETIREMENT FROM SEVEN FOR
SERVICE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR PRO
TEM ATKINS PREDECESSOR KEVIN DE
LEóN PRIOR TO MY POSITION TIME
WAS WITH THE PRO TEM I SPENT
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY WHERE I WAS
CHIEF OF THE WAYS AND MEANS
COMMITTEE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
MOST OF THE TIME THE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE. AND FOR
ALL THOSE YEARS I WAS ALSO
RESPONSIBLE. FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE POLICY- PRETTY MUCH ME
UPON MY RETURN. I WAS ASKED A
LONG TERM COLLEAGUE. GOVERNORS
ARE TO JOIN COMMISSION. AND I
WAS HAPPY TO DO SO. AS ONE OF
TWO NINE PEACE OFFICER
COMMISSION WAS POURED BY THE
GOVERNOR I'VE ATTEMPTED TO
BRING A CURRENT PUBLIC POLICY
FOCUS TO THE COMMISSION. ALONG
WITH THAT I'M GOING GENTLE PUSH
TO BE MORE ACTIVE MORE ACTIVE
PARTNER WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION TERMS
POLICY AND BUDGET- I POSTED
IMPROVED IMPROVES EVERY EVERY-
EVERY MEETING ON CHAD I.
COMPOSED THEIR BUDGETS BACK IN
THE EIGHTIES- SO SOME PROMOTERS
POSTS AND I'M AMAZED AND
IMPRESSED. AT THE GROWTH EVEN
OVER THE LAST FIVE OR TEN YEARS
I THINK MY EXPERIENCE USING
ABLE GOING TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
NATIONAL POST AND I HOPE. TO
CONTINUE THESE EFFORTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER LONG I.
COMMISSIONER AND SERGEANT
O'ROURKE. WELCOME. AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- IT IS AN HONOR FOR
ME TO SIT BEFORE USE YOU CAN IN
MY FELLOW COMMISSIONERS YOUR
CALL TO THE POST COMMISSION I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY FAMILY
FOR THEIR SUPPORT THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK
OF A REASON FOR THIS
REQUIREMENT AS WELL AS DIRECTOR
ALL RESIDENTS STAFF PRETTY
CREDIBLE WORK THEY'VE DONE
OPPOSED TO PROVIDE THE HIGHEST
LEVEL TRAINING RESOURCES FOR
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT I
CAN KERR OF THE PREVIOUS-
COMMISSIONERS THAT POSES DURING
AN OUTSTANDING JOB- AS ALWAYS
IT'S- THE- ARE. A LOT OF
DIALOGUE AND- DECISIONS ARE
MADE AND. I JUST APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY THANKS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COMMISSIONER AND
SERGEANT RAMIREZ WELCOME. YEAH
I NEED IT CAN HEAR ME OKAY YES
WE CAN THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR
SENATORS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY I'M GLAD TO BE
HERE TODAY I AM NOT. COSTA
COUNTY SERGEANT IN A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OVER TWENTY YEARS
I'VE BEEN ADMINISTRATION
SERGEANT HOMELESS LIAISON TEAM
SERGEANT IVAN THE PAST
PRESIDENT OF OUR UNION. AND I
AM CURRENTLY THE CHIEF DEPUTY
CORONER FOR FOSTER COUNTY AND
ON MY SENTIMENTS ALONG WITH ALL
THE COMMISSION IS A TOPIC FOR
ME I THINK GAP POSES COME A
LONG WAY ESPECIALLY WITH OUR
SELECTION OF MAPPING OUT
BRANDS. TAKING POSTED NEW
DIRECTION ARE YOU'VE GOT GREAT
PEOPLE IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY
AND ARE THEY ARE NOT AFRAID TO
SPEAK UP AND DO SOME HEALTHY
BANTER TO. HELP KEEP
PROGRESSING OUR POST FORWARD.
SEVEN THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. I YOU VERY MUCH. I
AM AGAIN GONNA START WITH
SENATOR BATES. NINE I'M NOT
NEEDED YEAH I KNOW WE CAN HEAR
YOU SENATOR- WILL. ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT ST THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE I WAS
LOOKING AT THE YEARS OF ARMS
OVER THIRTY YEARS OF SERVICE I
HAVE YOU HAVE ALL OF THE TIME
THAT YOU OFTEN GIVE A NOD TO
THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT STUFF
COMMISSION AND I KNOW ON GIVEN
THE LAST A YEAR- CERTAINLY
WOULD CALL ME CHALLENGES BUT
ALSO WITH. THE CHALLENGES IN
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT. ARENA THE
OF. FOR IS SIX IMPORTANT THAT
KNOW CHALLENGE YOUR SEATS BASED
ISSUES RESTORE JUST. THAT OF
LOCAL EASTER. AND ALL OF THAT.
I'D LIKE TO SEE TO FIRST YOUR-
SURGING ARE. WE WILL ANDREAS
SERGEANT COMMISSIONER AND EVEN
WE LIVE AND- THE OPRAH SERGEANT
WERE NEAR US YOUR CURRENT- YOU
WERE. THE R. KHARADI OF RED
RESTRAINT. FOR THE CONCERN
HAVEN'T SAFE ARE FOR THOSE
OFFICER ARE MIKE BE AN EARLY
AREA IN NEEDING A NEW NUMBER OF
THE TRYING TO RESPOND TO ANY.
MESSAGE THAT WERE IN WERE SOME
WHO IS VERY DIFFICULT TO RISK
SHE WERE COMES ABOUT THE- I
RECEIVED A CALL WHEN INTO FIND.
AN ALTERNATE ROUTE THAT COULD
BE USED IN TRAIN WILL TRAIN IN
ALL THE PREVIOUS TO ENSURE THAT
YOU COULD BE SAVORING YOU'RE
WAITING ARE A BACKUP SO COULD
YOU SPEAK A LITTLE- TO THAT AND
NOW WHAT THE AKAN DEALS OR WHAT
MIGHT BE A PROCESS. BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS A CONCERN YOU ARE
YOU KNOW A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
POUND OFFICER TRYING TO
RESTRAIN NOT THE. TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY POUNDS ON. INDIVIDUAL AND
YOU DON'T THE TO- IN THE- EXIST.
TO ENSURE OWN SAY. YEAH THAT
WOULD LEAD TO OUR CORE PLEASE
LEAVE FORCE AND I THINK WE- ALL
HOPING THAT WE CAN. THE SHE BE
JUST TO MAKE ON. THE LISLE
THROW IT TO YOU BUT YOU SURE
SOME THOUGHTS US. HOW WE GO. OR
ALL THE WOMEN IN SERVICE IN
PARTICULAR. THANK YOU SENATOR
NOT START WITH- SERGEANT OF- A
LITTLE AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
SERGEANT RAMIREZ. SURE SURE
THANK YOU- I KNOW THERE IS A
LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT THE
CAROTID RESTRAINT DUE TO THE
EVENTS THAT OCCURRED- I'LL
SWEAR IN THE COUNTRY. WHERE
FOLKS HAVE HAVE. DIED WHILE IN
CONTACT WITH POLICE OFFICERS
AND- THAT THE CONCERN WAS OVER
YOU KNOWTHE USE OF THE CROWDED
RESTRAINT. BUT IT THINK AT ANY
TIME- ANY TYPE OF FORCE. THAT
IS USED OR APPLIED INCORRECTLY
CAN BE FATAL SO THAT'S WHY WE
DON'T USE BATONS ON PEOPLE'S
HEADS OR ON THEIR NEXT WE DON'T
USED TASERS. ON THE ELDERLY- OR
CHILDREN- BUT THIS DID CAUSE ME
CONCERN BECAUSE WHENEVER WE
TAKE A TOOL OR TECHNIQUES THAT
HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO BE
EFFECTIVE- WE TAKE AWAY. WE
TAKE AWAY AS OPTIONS. FOR US
FOR OFFICERS AND THAT'S-
TURNING ESPECIALLY WE'RE NOT
READILY REPLACE THEM WITH. THAT
IS JUST AS GOOD IF NOT BETTER-
AND I'M HOPING THAT. UP BECAUSE
OF THIS DECISION TO DO AWAY
WITH THE CAROTID RESTRAINT THAT
IT CREATES. OR OPPORTUNITIES
FOR INNOVATION- FOR US TO
EXPLORE WHAT ELSE IS OUT THERE-
THAT YOU KNOW WE BRING PEOPLE
IN FROM- PROFESSIONS- YOU KNOW
PROFESSIONAL FIGHTERS OR THOSE
WHO HAVE- INNOVATIVE TOOLS-
SUCH AS I MEAN THAT THE TASER
WASN'T HASN'T BEEN AROUND
FOREVER BUT IT DID COME AROUND
AT SOME POINT SO. IF SOMEONE
BUT SOMEONE WERE TO CREATE OR
INVENT SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
USEFUL I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
GO IN THE DIRECTION WHERE-
WE'RE USING INNOVATION TO OUR
ADVANTAGE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SERGEANT ROMERO'S. I AGREE WITH
SERGEANT- WE ARE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS BROUGHT UP
DURING THE MEETING DISCUSSING
THAT IS YOU KNOW MAYBE TEACHING
A LITTLE MORE GROUND FIGHTING-
AND I OFFERED AT DIGITS TO AND
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK
LIKE DO WE EXTEND THE ACADEMY
DO WE MAKE IT HARDER TO MAYBE
GETTING YOUR CERTIFICATE PRETTY
IN A LITTLE BIT ON THE- TRAINEE
THEMSELVES THAT. AS THEIR
STARTING OUT THAT ARE YOU KNOW
YOU MAKE IT MAY BE PART OF THE
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE SOME GROUND FIGHTING RIGHT
ALONG WITH YOUR HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA FIVE BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
FIND OF LATE SOMETHING TO
REPLACE IT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT ANSWER IS RIGHT NOW R. I
THINK RIGHT NOW THAT. THE
QUICKER. FIX WOULD BE ARE YOU
KNOW MAYBE SOME JUJITSU SKILLS
WHERE YOU CAN. ACTUALLY GET
YOURSELF IN A POSITION TO HOLD
SOMEONE DOWN. LONG ENOUGH
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
TECHNIQUES YOU CAN HOLD SOMEONE
LONG ENOUGH TO GET SOMEONE
THERE TO HELP WELL THAT ALWAYS
SOLVE THE PROBLEM NO THERE'S
GONNA BE TIMES THAT WE HAVE TO
USE LEGAL THAT WE'RE JUST NOT
GOING TO. HAVE A CHOICE BUT I
THINK THAT'S THAT GOING
FORWARD. THAT'S ONE THING WE
SHOULD CONSIDER AND LOOK INTO
AND SEE YOU KNOW. HOW THAT HOW
COULD POSSIBLY INCORPORATE THAT
INTO THE ACADEMIES. ARE MAKING
MAYBE HAVING TO MAKE THE
ECONOMY A LITTLE BIT LONGER OR-
AS YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID MAKE IT
MAYBE PART OF THE REQUIREMENT
IT GETTING HIRED INTO LAW
ENFORCEMENT- GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. SENATOR BATES OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. I JUST WANT
TO THANK THEM FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. I
THINK WE'RE ALL VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE- USE OF LETHAL FORCE
AND WHAT THAT HAS RENDERED JOHN
TO THE PUBLIC OVER THE LAST A
YEAR AND A HALF. CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW FINDING NEW AND INNOVATIVE
WAYS TO ENSURE PROTECTION ARE.
ON THE PUBLIC AND CERTAINLY OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IS MY
HIGHEST PRIORITY I THINK FOR
ALL. SO THANK YOU FOR CALLING
JUST INTRODUCING THE CONCERN
AND THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
FOCUSED ON FINDING. AND I.
ACTUALLY ON THINK THE- OFF
MISSIONERS THAT ARE. LISTENING
TAKING ON DAHLE CERTAIN WITH
TODAY YOU ALL MY- SUPPORT
LOOKING AT THE YEARS THAT YOU.
DEVOTED TO THEIR OUTSTANDING
YOU DON'T GET ANY COMPENSATION
SO. YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
CASH YOUR NAY ON HOW CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE VERY HERE
YOU. TO AND WILL BE SOLD
PRESHEAF BACK. SO I'M NOT GOING
TO HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS I WOULD JUST ASK THAT
LISTENING TO YOU ON. OUR OTHER
WOMEN OFFICERS HERE IN THE
CONCERNS ON IT IS NOT LIKE IT
IS ON TV WHERE SOMEONE THAT'S
NINETY SIX POUNDS IS ABLE TO
RESTRAIN A THREE HUNDRED. POUND
PERSON ON THE GROUND AND ALL
LOOKS WONDERFUL INSURANCE AFTER
TAKING WE KNOW THAT'S NOT WHAT
YOU'RE UP AGAINST SO. ALL OF
YOU- FOCUSING AND DEDICATING
TIME TO. JUST SOLVING THAT
ISSUE I THINK IS GOING TO BE ON
GREAT MAC THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
SERVICE YOU ARE OFFERING STATE.
BUT WHAT THAT YOU ALL HAVE- MY
STRONG ACROSS THE PORCH AND- I
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO BUILDING
I'D- GET. TO THAT THANK YOU
AGAIN. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES-
MISTER. LEADER I AM THANK SO
MUCH QUESTION ANSWER THANK YOU
THANK ARE MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU VERY TEM AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR RE APPOINTMENT AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO VOTING TO
CONFIRM I'M SURE THROUGH THIS
QUESTION ON WHOEVER WANTS TO
ADDRESS A CAN WE HAD A NUMBER
OF LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS- IN
NOT ONLY OUR BODY WITH THE
STATE ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR AS IT
RELATES TO DECERTIFYING
OFFICERS. SO RECOGNIZING THE
POSTERS ON HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DECERTIFY OFFICERS I'M
INTERESTED IN YOUR THOUGHTS ON
IF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
SHOULD BE LICENSE ALREADY
CERTIFIED BY STATE ENTITY AND
IF SO DO YOU THINK POST IS THE
RIGHT ENTITY TO DO THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I ANYONE THAT
WOULD WANT TO- RESPOND TO THAT
CAN. FIVE I WILL IT I KNOW IT'S
HARD WHEN THERE ARE FIVE PEOPLE
AT ONCE AND WE'RE NOT IN A ROOM
WITH. GO AHEAD GOING AND PICKLE
MISTER LONG OKAY OKAY. YOU KNOW
OKAY. GO AHEAD MR LONG. I AM
VERY INTERESTED IN IN THE
CERTIFICATION AND- WE AS A
COMMISSION HAD A LONG
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS I THINK
ABOUT THIS PRE COATED. AGING
CONVERSATION AS AS MOST THE
POST CONVERSATIONS GOES A GREAT
DEAL CAN TAKE ONE OF THE
COMMISSIONERS HAD ASKED- THE
STAFF TO DO A REPORT ON
DECERTIFICATION THIS IS
PROBABLY ABOUT MAYBE TWO YEARS
AGO. A FORMER POLICE- OF A
POLICE CHIEF WHO IS A FORMER
MEMBER FALLS FOR A GREAT
DISCUSSION I'M VERY INTRIGUED
EMOTIONAL DECERTIFICATION I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD
PURSUE- IT'S IN THE DETAILS-
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS QUITE.
EXTENSIVE DEBATE OVER THIS
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR AND I
ASSUME IT WILL BE AGAIN I THINK
IT COMES DOWN TO. WHO DOES THE
INVESTIGATIONS AND HOW BIG OF A
STRUCTURED YOU MOVED TO CREATE
ADDITIONAL BOARD ADDITIONAL
DIVISION YOU CAN POST IS NOT
NOW AND NEVER HAS BEEN A
TRIBUNAL SO THERE'S THAT ISSUE
GIVEN TO ALSO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
GET ITO. WHAT WILL. BE A AN
OFFENSE WORTHY OF
DECERTIFICATION GETTING THE
DEFINITIONS OF THE LIST OF
OFFENSES ONCE YOU GO DOWN THAT
ROAD OF LISTING OFFENSES- AS
THOSE SORTS OF WORKING PUBLIC
POLICY FOR MANY YEARS NOW THOSE
LISTS ARE CROSS REFERENCING
REFERRED TO FOR YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS. FIGURED BURKE
CAREFUL ON HOW THOSE ARE
DRAFTED I PERSONALLY THINK A
CALIFORNIA SHOULD JOIN THE-
BALANCE OF STATES I THINK IT'S-
LIKE FORTY FIVE STATES WHO HAVE
THE CERTIFICATION BUT I THINK
THE DEVIL IS ALWAYS IN THE
DETAILS HERE. WHO IS TO DO THE-
RESTRICTIONS SINCE TRIBUNAL.
AND HOW YOU CAN DO THE
DEFINITIONS. SO THAT'S MY TAKE
MOMENT. THANK YOU MSTER. ARE
ANYONE IS. WOULD BE A- IN YOUR
CALL ON THIS. WELL I THINK IT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
TO TRY TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS A MATTER
OF LEGISLATIVE- DISCUSSION THIS
YEAR AND- IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO KNOW THAT. SHARE NOW ARE
STARTING DON JUAN THANK ONE
OKAY GO AHEAD YOU YOU FIRST AND
THEN I SAW SERGEANT ROMERO'S
HAND AS WELL GO AHEAD. CHANCE
THE SECOND PART OF THE QUESTION
I THINK AFFIRMATIVELY POSISI
ABSOLUTE IDEAL. ENTITY WHEN THE
STATE TO IMPLEMENT WHATEVER.
THAT COMES OUT ALL COMES OUT OF
MY LEGISLATION AT THE END OF
THE DAY MUCH OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALREADY THERE
THROUGH. APPLE'S IMPLEMENTED.
GIVEN THE WAY THAT THIS STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OUR
STRUCTURE ALREADY EXISTS. M. I
THINK COMMISSIONER ALONG IS
RIGHT ON THE MONEY I THINK THE
ISSUE IS GOING TO BE THE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS AND HOW
THE IMPLEMENTATION. AND HOW WE
ACTUALLY GET TO A STRUCTURE
THAT WORKS FOR ALL BUT I THINK
THAT I WOULD JOIN PROBABLY ALL
THE- COMMISSIONERS AND POST IN
SAYING THAT POSTED IS
ABSOLUTELY READY TO TAKE ON
THAT CHALLENGE. AND FIND A WAY
TO GET THIS DONE. THANK YOU
SERGEANT I SERGEANT REMAIN. ED
I WAS JUST GONNA ADD TO THE
SAME THING REPLACED I THINK
POST WOULD BE THE RIGHT PLACE I
THINK YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER RIGHT- PRESSURE LONG
SAID THE DEVIL IS IN THE
DETAILS BUT ALSO I THINK THAT
WOULD ALSO OPEN UP LIKE YOU
KNOW THE STAFF BEING THEM
PROPERLY AND GIVING THEM
ANOTHER SAID THE UNIT TO BE
ABLE TO HANDLE THE AMOUNT OF
WORK THAT THEY WOULD BE TASKED
WITH. THANK YOU COM ANYTHING
FURTHER. OKAY THANK YOU MATT
OKAY SENATOR LAYERED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND-
REALLY THE SCOPE OF POSTERS IN
TWO THINGS TRAINING AND POLICE
PRACTICES AND SELECTION
STANDARDS AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE DONE A GREAT
JOB OF SORT OF GETTING INTO
SOME OF THE ISSUES OF TRAINING
AND POLICE ARE PRACTICES SO I
HAD ONE QUESTION I THOUGHT I
WOULD START WITH JEFF LONG AND
THAT IS ON THE SELECTION
STANDARDS I KNOW IN SOME WAYS
IT AND WE TALKED ABOUT THIS I
KNOW IN SOME WAYS THEY'RE WROTE
OR THEY'RE OUT THERE BUT HOW DO
YOU DEAL. WITH THE ISSUES OF
DIVERSITY IN RECRUITMENT OF
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
AGAINST A SELECTION STANDARDS
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU CAN DO
THAT CAN FACILITATE THAT
DIVERSITY OR THERE ARE THINGS
YOU OF OBSERVE GENERATIONS THAT
MIGHT BE IN SOMEBODY ELSE'S
ARENA ON THAT. WELL THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED- I THINK
SELECTION IS A HUGE ISSUE I
THINK DIVERSITY IS A HUGE ISSUE
IT IS NOT HERE TO FOR REALLY
BEEN- AN ISSUE FOR POST BECAUSE
THE SELECTION STANDARDS ARE
LARGELY STATUTORY IN POSTAL
WE'RE ON SOME ADDITIONAL
STANDARDS MAYBE IN TERMS OF.
EDUCATION OR OR- THINGS LIKE
THAT AS VERY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES CARE ON TOP OF THAT
BUT IN TERMS OF SELECTIONS
ESPECIALLY REACHING OUT FOR
DIVERSITY. IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE
REALLY GOT TO LOOK AT. THE
NUMBERS- THE NUMBERS ARE-
THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT- PURCHASE
OF THE- POPULATION IS WHITE YOU
KNOW AND BUT 52% OF- POLICE
OFFICERS OR WHAT THE BIGGEST BY
FAR- DISCREPANCIES WITH WOMEN
ONLY ABOUT 14% OF THE SOURCES
OF. WITH OBVIOUSLY MORE THAN
HALF OF THE POPULATION WELL AS
SOMETHING THAT HAS GREAT
RAMIFICATIONS FOR I THINK WHOSE
LEGITIMACY AND- TRUST AND
TRANSPARENCY AND SO FORTH SO.
WE'VE GOT TO TRY TO ENGAGE IN A
WAY TO ENCOURAGE MORE DIVERSITY
IN TERMS OF HIRING THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME SOME EFFORTS- THE
EEOC SAID- DEAL J. AS IN
ADVANCING. SURE DIVERSITY
TRAINING IN AND- SELECTION AND
RECRUITMENT. IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE DUE FOR
POSTERS REALLY ENGAGED AND I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WILL
BE TALKED ABOUT- COMING FOR
WHETHER IT'S AS SIMPLE AS A
SEPARATE STATEMENTS OF INTENT
OR WHETHER IT'S TRYING TO MAYBE
EVEN DO. SOME TYPE OF-
CERTAINLY TO FIND OUT EXACTLY
WHAT THE VARIOUS AGENCIES ARE
DOING AND WHAT IS WHAT IS NOT
ORANGE FRUIT WELL I SEE THAT.
IT IS A MAN FROM WHAT YOU SAY
POST DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF
DISCRETION BUT PULSE. COLLECTS
DISTANT THE STATISTICS AND
MONITORS THE SITUATION IN A WAY
THAT YOU CONNECT TO VIA. THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU JUST
EXPRESSED IT MARKED REFLECT ON
THIS I MEAN IS. IF FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S ONE PROPOSAL. I DON'T
WANT TO GET. TO INTO. OUR
LEGISLATION BUT THERE'S ONE
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD SORT OF
LIFT THE AGE TO GO IN AND IT IN
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BASED ON
STATISTICS DO YOU HAVE SOME
VIEW THAT THAT WOULD AFFECT
DIVERSITY AND SOMEONE. OUR
PERSONAL VIEW ON THAT A LITTLE
BIT OF A CONCERN BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT I DO AGREE WITH YOU
CENTER THE POST IS IN
POSSESSION OF STATISTICS AND
WRITE AFFECTED THINKING APRIL.
WHAT REPORT OUT THERE WILL
BREAK DOWN THE ACADEMY'S- IN
TERMS OF DIVERSITY AND THAT
WILL BE A VERY INTERESTING I
THINK WE SHOULD GO FOR PERSONAL
I THINK WE SHOULD GO FURTHER.
AND LOOK AT DEPARTMENTS DO SOME
ADDITIONAL REPORTING AND FIND
OUT YOU KNOW WHAT THE VARIOUS
BREAKDOWNS ARE AND WHAT'S
WORKING IN TERMS OF THEIR-
REACHING OUT IN TERMS OF
DIVERSITY- IN TERMS OF RAISING
THE AGE AS- RAGING EDUCATIONAL
LEVEL. WELL THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE INTERESTING THINGS TO
TALK ABOUT I ALSO THINK WE HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL BY MAYBE THE M.
TEN CONSEQUENCES OF ACTUALLY
MAKING NARROWING. THE
POPULATIONS THAT WE ARE SEEKING
TO INCREASE TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE DON'T ACCOMPANY SUCH THINGS
AS- ADDITIONAL EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS SAY COLLEGE
DEGREES OR ORIGINALLY AGE TO
TWENTY FIVE WE DON'T. IF WE
DON'T ATTACHED TO THOSE THINGS-
DIFFERENT STANDARDS FOR
REACHING OUT AND LOOKING AT THE
POPULATIONS THAT WE'RE SEEKING
IF WE DON'T TIE THOSE TWO
THINGS TOGETHER I THINK THERE
COULD BE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. OF SUCH A BILL MY
OWN JUST IN MY OWN OPINION TECH
PARTNERSHIPS AT NIGHT. IF I
HAVE TO RECOUNT A STORY AS
USUAL AND- I WAS SPEAKING AT
THE GRADUATION OF THE BATCH LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR PARK RANGERS
AND I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DIVERSITY. AND THE FRONT THERE
WERE FIFTY IN THE FRONT ROW THE
SEVEN OF THEM WERE ALL WOMEN I
WAS VERY EXCITED AND THEN I
REALIZED. THAT THESE VERY
SEATED. THEM IN ORDER OF THEIR
HEIGHT. THERE WERE SEVEN WOMEN
IN ENTIRE. THEY WERE IN THE ROW
THEY WERE THE SHORTEST AND SO.
THE SOME FOR DIVERSE. LET ME
FLY CALL. AND I HATE TO DO THIS
THE MAIL OF THE OTHER
CANDIDATES BUT I KNOW THERE
WERE OTHER PEOPLE THERE DID
ANYBODY HAVE ANYTHING THEY WISH
TO ADD ON THAT ISSUE BEFORE WE
MOVE ON. BUT SENATOR I WOULD
SLIDE LIBRARY. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD SIR. YES THANK YOU YEAH
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
STRUGGLED WITH AS A PROFESSION
FOR A VERY LONG TIME I MEAN
EVEN. WHEN I STARTED IN-
NINETEEN A CERTAIN A STUDENT
TRAINEE ACTUALLY IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO I WAS ONLY NINETEEN
YEARS OLD WHEN MY AGENCY
RECRUITED ME FROM THE LOCAL
COLLEGE- AND I MEAN I'VE WORKED
IT YOU KNOW TO HELP OUR
RECRUITING A UNIT FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AND NOW WE STILL AREN'T
AT THE LEVELS THAT WE WANT TO
BE- BUT I THINK PART OF THAT.
IS DUE TO SOME OF THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE HAVE WITH
US SOME OF THE COMMUNITIES- IT
IN OUR AREA I THINK THAT THAT.
THAT'S THE SAME FOR A LOT OF
THE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
NATION- WE HAVE MADE A LOT OF
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THE-
RELATIONSHIPS IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO- RECRUIT FROM WITHIN-
SO. AS I DO UNDERSTAND THE NEED
AND THE VALUE AND DIVERSITY
BECAUSE I MEAN I'M HERE AND I
UTILIZE MY AGE MY LANGUAGE
SKILLS AND- EFFECTIVE A WOMAN
ALL THE TIME. TO HELP ME BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THIS JOB BUT I
CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. TO CONCENTRATE
ON HOW WE TREAT PEOPLE OVERALL-
CONTINUING WITH THE PROCEDURAL
JUSTICE THE- TRAINING SO THAT
YOU KNOW PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE BEEN TREATED FAIRLY BY THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THAT'S HOW WE
GET PEOPLE TO. ON SHOULDN'T
HAVE TRUST IN US AS POLICE
OFFICERS AND IN THIS PROFESSION
SO THAT THEY WOULD WANT TO COME
AND WORK HERE- IT ONLY TAKES
ONE PERSON AND NO MATTER THEIR
WHITE BLACK ASIAN OR WHATEVER
TO YOU KNOW DO SOMETHING
INAPPROPRIATE TO CREATE
MISTRUST OR TO DESTROY IT IN A
COMMUNITY- AND SO REALLY IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT YOUR RACE
IS OR WHAT YOUR GENDER IS I
THINK IT'S THE OVER OVERALL WAY
IN WHICH WE TREAT PEOPLE THAT
MATTERS MOST AND I THINK WE
NEED TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON THAT. THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU AND
I THINK- SERGEANT RAMIREZ
WANTED TO ALSO COMMENT ON THIS.
YES HI I WAS JUST GONNA SAY
THAT I THINK THAT WE NEED TO DO
A BETTER JOB OF RECRUITING-
WOMEN. AND MINORITIES OUT BY
GOING ON THE FIELD BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT'S ANYTHING THAT'S
HOST REALLY. ARM CAN CONTROL I
THINK IT'S MORE ON THE AGENCIES
THEMSELVES THAT THEY NEED TO
GET OUT IN THE MORE. ARE
DIVERSE AREAS- BUT KIND OF ON
WHAT LINE I SAID YOU KNOW IT
ALSO DEPENDS ON THE
RELATIONSHIP YOU HAVE WITH THE
COMMUNITY WHETHER THEY WANT TO
LET YOU AND THEY'RE TO DO
THINGS OR NOT BUT YOU KNOW.
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS DIFFERENT AGENCIES YOU
CAN TRY. TO RECRUIT FEMALES AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW GOING TO ALL
WOMEN EVENTS LIKE YOU KNOW ALL
WOMEN RUNS WELL WHEN BEFORE
CALVET- BUT WE JUST NEED TO GET
OUT THERE MORE AND I THINK WE
NEED TO GET OUR WOMEN OUT THERE
MORE. SENDING MEN OUT TO THOSE-
TYPE OF EVENTS TO TRY TO QUIT-
RECRUIT WOMEN DOESN'T ALWAYS
WORK THE BEST SO I THINK THAT.
WE HAVE TO PUT A LOT MORE ON
THE AGENCIES INDIVIDUALLY TO GO
OUT AND I KNOW PERSONALLY OUR
AGENCY TRIED TO RECRUIT WOMEN
AND I'VE BEEN IN INTERVIEWS
BEFORE WHERE THEY LIKE I KNOW
I'M GOOD I DON'T. THIS REALLY
ISN'T WHAT I WANT TO DO. HOW DO
THEY GO TO ALL. SO I THINK IT'S
JUST- A LITTLE BIT ON WHAT
WHILE I SAID THAT I YOU KNOW.
THE IMAGE THAT WE KEEP AND-
MAKING WANTED. PEOPLE WANT TO
DO THIS AND UNFORTUNATELY PRESS
RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN A- STRANGE
TIME WHERE WE'RE GETTING A LOT
OF. BAD PUBLICITY AND- THAT
PERSON HAS A CHOICE BETWEEN
BEING WHAT THEY THINK IS YOU
KNOW A- PROFESSION WHERE WE'RE
NOT. ARE DOING THINGS THE RIGHT
WAY I THINK YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
TRY TO. TRY TWICE AS HARD NOW
TO RECRUIT. BECAUSE WE HAVE
THAT STIGMA THAT WERE ALL UP
AGAIN SO. I THINK GETTING WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR JUST GONNA
BE A LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT THAN
IT HAS BEEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGER THANK YOU- IT WILL
TO FOLLOW ALONG ON THAT I KNOW
THAT I'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
WITH FORMER COMMISSIONER
STANLEY OF CHP AND WITH
COMMISSIONER- RAY WHO HAS YET
TO COME BEFORE US AND WILL- AT
SOME POINT FOR CONFIRMATION- AS
IT RELATES TO THE ACADEMY'S AND
SOME OF THE TRAININGS THERE
HAVE BEEN STUDIES DONE THAT
POINT TO. VARIOUS REQUIREMENTS
THAT WORK FOR SOME-
COMMUNITIES- THAT HAVE A
DISADVANTAGED- SOME COMMUNITIES
FOR INSTANCE THE DRIVING
CRITERIA- I YEAH MY YEAH. MY
STAFF- THAT COVERS ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE'VE GONE OVER
THIS AGAIN AND AGAIN AND IN MY
MOST RECENT CONVERSATION WITH
COMMISSIONER RAY I ASK ABOUT
THOSE THINGS AND THERE WAS
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER. THERE
ARE OBVIOUSLY- TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS WHERE PEOPLE DON'T
PASS A CERTAIN TRAINING AND
THEY DROP OUT OF THE PROGRAM
THEY DROP OUT OF THE ACADEMY
AND THERE TEND TO BE SOME TREND
LINES IN TERMS OF- THE ETHNIC
DIVERSITY ON THOSE THINGS- I
DIDN'T THINK TO HAVE ALL THAT
MATERIAL WITH ME TODAY BUT IT
CAME UP AGAIN AT LEAST TWO
TIMES WITH- FORMER
COMMISSIONERS AT CHP WHEN WE
ALWAYS ASK THAT QUESTION WHEN
THE COMMISSIONERS COME IN. HOW
ARE YOU WORKING ON DIVERSITY
AND IT WOULD SEEM- THERE IS A
ROLE ACTUALLY FOR POST- IN THAT
BUT JUST TO COMMENT I DON'T I
DON'T NEED- THAT ANSWERED- BUT
I DO WANT TO ASK THIS QUESTION
BECAUSE IT'S A DIFFERENT.
QUESTION DO YOU BELIEVE THERE
ARE ACCURATE OR VERIFIABLE WAYS
TO IDENTIFY BIASED OFFICERS
ACTUALLY BEFORE YOU HIRE THEM
AND- ARE MOST OF THE- LAW
ENFORCEMENT- COMMISSIONERS HERE
HAVE QUITE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
AND I WOULD IMAGINE. YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THAT IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO AND I WOULD I WOULD
ACTUALLY ASK OUR- AGAIN IT'S SO
HARD TO. ASK PEOPLE JUST WANT
TO RESPOND. LET ME JUST GO DOWN
THE LIST AND ASK- SERGEANT
PARTICULARLY THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ONCE BUT MISTER
LONG YOU CAN CERTAINLY ANSWER
IF YOU'D LIKE- A SERGEANT OF- A
LITTLE COMMENTS ON IF YOU'RE
ABLE TO. DETERMINED THAT. THE
HIGHER YOUR TO YOUR YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE BIAS RIGHT
YES I'M SORRY PLEASE FORGIVE ME
I THOUGHT I SAID BIASED OFF YES
YES IMPLICIT BIAS. SO WE I MEAN
EVERYBODY EVERYBODY HAS A BIAS
IT'S MATTER OF US TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE HAVE THAT BIAS RIGHT
CAN'T GET UNDER CONTROL RIGHT
NOT USING THAT WHILE WE'RE AT
WORK- BUT YOU KNOW WE- THE
OFFICERS ARE REQUIRED TO GO
THROUGH PSYCHOLOGICAL SCREENING
PRIOR TO- YOU KNOW BEING
ACCEPTED INTO THE ACADEMY SO I
AM. BUT I'M NOT SURE WHETHER OR
NOT THIS THERE HAS BEEN
EMPHASISED- AND THAT SCREENING
PROCESS TO ROOT OUT BIAS- IF
NOT THEN THAT'S SOMETHING WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO LOOK AT THAT.
AS YOU KNOW POST NEEDS O LOOK
AT AND- PUT MORE EMPHASIS ON IT
ARE AT WE DO PROVIDE AS YOU
PROBABLY ALREADY KNOW- THE- THE
BIAS TRAINING. FOR THOSE OF US
WHO ARE WERE ALREADY SWORN-
JUST SO THAT WE CAN. BRING THAT
ATTENTION TO EVERYBODY AND YOU
KNOW MAKE SURE THAT WERE
RECOGNIZING THAT WITHIN
OURSELVES AND TO DEAL WITH IT
PROPERLY. THANK YOU SERGEANT
DONLAN DO YOU WANNA COMMENT.
YES MADAM CHAIR I WOULD AGREE
WITH THE COMMISSION PERFORMING
VERSION WILLIAM BUT YEAH I
REALLY JUST FEEL THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT A CANDIDATE AND THEY'RE
ABOUT TO ENTER THE ACADEMY YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A HOLISTIC VIEW OF
THEM IT'S NOT JUST IN. EUROPE
PSYCHOLOGICAL PROFILING IS ANY
INDICATION WHATSOEVER BIAS IN
THE BACKGROUND THEY HAVE NO
PLACE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AB
RESPECTIVELY FROM THAT ONCE
YOU'RE ACTUALLY SERVING AND
YEAH AGENCIES I THINK I'VE DONE
A GOOD JOB MAKING VERY CLEAR
THAT BIASES ON ACCEPTABLE AND
POST HAS ALSO BEEN ON THE
VANGUARD IN PROMULGATING AT
PROCEDURAL JUSTICE AS A WAY TO.
ADD TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
AN ISSUE AND ENSURE THAT AT WE
ADDRESS IT IMMEDIATELY AND- I
THINK THAT. YEAH CATION IS CAN
CHANGE TO. DEAL WITH THIS
CHALLENGE AND LIKE A LOT OF
WERE ABOLISHED AND AS LONG AS I
MESSAGES IT HAS NO PLACE IN OUR
PROFESSION AND IF IT COMES IF
IT'S DEMONSTRATED PEOPLE SHOULD
KNOW BUSINESS WHEREIN ACT
UNIFORM ABOUT YOUR SERVICES
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SERGEANT
SERGEANT O'ROURKE YOU WANT TO
ADD ANYTHING TO THAT. YEAH I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH THE
COMMISSION ON THERE THAT
THROUGHOUT THE BACKGROUND
PROCESSES THINGS POPS UP THEY
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD NOT BE
THROUGH THE BACKGROUND- AS WELL
AS AS THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
THEIR ACADEMY IF ANYTHING RISES
TO THEIR THAT IS JUST ANOTHER.
REASON TO SPOTLIGHT THAT
CANDIDATE AND SEE IF THEY'RE UP
TO THE CRITERIA THAT NEEDS-
WELL WITH THE PROPER BACKGROUND
AND- AND VALUES ARE BECOMING
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THANK YOU.
SERGEANT ROMERO'S ANYTHING.
YEAH I THINK THAT THERE'S WAYS
TO KIND OF SCREEN THESE THINGS
BEFORE WE EVEN YOU KNOW GET
INTO THE PROCESS AND I THINK IT
GOES BACK WITH AGENCIES ON HOW
THEY'RE TESTING QUESTIONS THAT
THEY'RE ASKING ARE WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR AND JUST REALLY
BRIEFLY I GET A SMALL STUDY ON
MY OWN WITH A- CLOSE VIDEO. OF
A TRAFFIC STOP AND JUST
RANDOMLY ASK MY EMPLOYEES AS
THEY WERE WALKING BY. WHAT THEY
THOUGHT IT GOT THEIR OPINION
AND- IT WAS INTERESTING TO SEE
THEIR THOUGHT PROCESS OF BEING
GAUGE MAN I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WATCH THE VIDEO OR NOT BUT IT'S
WITH A TRAFFIC STOP WITH A
WHITE OFFICER AND- BLACK
DRYBURGH BLACK YOUNG MAN. AND
THAT RIGHT THERE GAVE ME AN
INDICATION. IT WAS IN THE JAIL
SETTING UP WHAT PEOPLE I'D LIKE
TO SEE WHERE FORWARD AS
DEPUTIES AND WHAT ONES WERE.
PROBABLY NOT SUITED FOR IT IT
WAS VERY INTERESTING SO IT JUST
MAKES ME THINK THAT THERE ARE
WAYS FOR US TO BE ABLE TO MEET
SOME OF THESE THINGS OUT.
BEFORE ANYBODY GETS IN THE
PROCESS AND WE START SPENDING
THE MONEY AND TRYING TO HELP
THEM SURVIVE- WHEN WILL NEED TO
HAVE THESE PROBLEMS COME UP
LATER. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER LONG I DON'T LEAVE
YOU OUT OF THIS. QUESTION Q. I.
INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT-
PROFESSIONALS FIRST BUT YOU ARE
A PROFESSIONAL ALSO IN TERMS OF
YOUR OBSERVATION SO THOUGHTS. I
WOULD AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE ONE THING I WOULD ADD IT
WOULD THINK I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT SUPPOSED TO STAY N
TOP OF THIS IS KIND OF MOTION
OF THIRD PARTY VALIDATION. OF
POST RAGS ON TOP OF STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS YOU HAVE- REQUIRE
SPECIFIC ORAL. ORAL INTERVIEWS
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION PSYCH
INVESTIGATIONS AND SO FORTH SO.
WE'RE COVERED ON THAT THE
QUESTION IS EFFICACY AND THERE
SHOULD BE SEEN OUR TRUCKS GOING
FORWARD HOW TO MEASURE IN ORDER
TO DO SO OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO HAVE MORE
INFORMATION SO MORE RESEARCH
CAN BE DONE. FICTIVE EXISTING
ROADS ARE IN ONE WAY TO DO THAT
I THINK WOULD BE YOUR FAULT ALL
THE I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF
THIRD PARTY VALIDATION WHETHER
IT'S- ACADEMIC. ACADEMICS- HERE
IS A OR WHAT BUT IT THINK IN
THIS CASE THIRD PER CALLED A
FROM THEIR- WOULD. GIVE US SOME
WINDOW INTO HOW EFFECTIVE-
REQUIREMENTS ARE MEETING UP
THESE PEOPLE. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES I WOULD JUST SAY IN
TERMS OF POST- AND YOUR MISSION
STATEMENT OUR STATED MISSION-
IN TERMS OF- THE
PROFESSIONALISM OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT SERVING
COMMUNITIES. I AM TALKING ABOUT
I BEING COMMITTED TO A VISION
OF THE FUTURE THAT ENSURES
QUALITY INTEGRITY
ACCOUNTABILITY COOPERATION.
ENCOURAGES NEW IDEAS EXPLORES
AND USES APPROPRIATE
TECHNOLOGIES DELIVERS RELEVANT
CLIENT BASE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. WHEN YOU MARRY THAT
MISSION WITH A CHANGING SOCIETY
AS WE HAVE SEEN CHANGING KIND
OF MORES AND LEVELS OF
EXPECTATION FROM THE PUBLIC
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME. I WOULD
ASK YOU ABOUT THAT AS WE GO TO
THE- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TEST OF FIVE BECAUSE- I'M
INTERESTED- YOU KNOW HOW FAR
AHEAD DOES PUBLISHED. GET AHEAD
OF COMMUNITY AND HOW MUCH ARE
YOU. ARE BEING DRIVEN BY
COMMUNITY TO THEN MOVE FORWARD
IF THAT'S A UNDERSTANDABLE
CONCEPT TO MAKE YOU'LL THINK
ABOUT THAT WILL GIVE YOU THE
FINAL WORD. ON THAT YEAH IN
TERMS OF THOUGHTS BUT I'LL GIVE
YOU TIME TO COLLECT YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
OUR EXPECTATION OF WHAT POST IS
MEANT TO OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR A NUMBER OF
DECADES. I RECALL AS THE AS A
STAFF MEMBER TO A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER HEARING ABOUT POST AND
TALKING TO POLICE OFFICERS ON
THE GROUND IN SAN DIEGO ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANT AND
THAT WAS TWENTY YEARS AGO- AND
HERE WE ARE DECADES LATER AND
THERE'S A CHANGING PERSPECTIVE
FROM COMMUNITY. ON WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE IT PUTS A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON YOU I IN TERMS OF
THE WORK THAT YOU DO AND ON
YOUR MISSION- I'M GOOD A. L.
COME BACK TO YOU BUT I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD AND GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. ARE WHO WANT TO.
AND TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
CONFIRMATION OF THESE OF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMISSION ON
POLICE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING TODAY. AND AS A
REMINDER FOR WITNESSES WISHING
TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA PHONE
THAT PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AGAIN IS. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO
HOURS EXCUSE ME. NINE TWO FOUR
ONE FOUR FIVE EIGHT. WE WILL
START AS PEOPLE ARE QUEUING UP
IN THE TELECONFERENCE WORLD
RIGHT HERE IN THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. R. FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
AND SEEING NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE LET ME MOVED TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE AND SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE WAITING IN THE
QUEUE NO NOT IN ROOM TWELVE. SO
I'M GONNA GO BACK TO MISTER
MODERATOR AND- SEE IF THERE ARE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. AND MR MODERATOR IF
YOU ARE THERE AND WANT TO QUEUE
UP THE WITNESSES AND TELL ME
HOW MANY FOLKS YOU MIGHT HAVE
IN THE QUEUE I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT AND GO AHEAD. SURE- IF YOU
LIKE TO FIND IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
HAD ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ARE
WE HAVE ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
HEADLINE SEVENTEEN. ONE SEVENTY
HAS DROPPED OKAY- HEY LET'S
GIVE IT ONE SECOND FROM. OKAY
MISTER MODERATOR IF THERE IS NO
ONE THERE. WE WILL COME BACK
INTO A ROOM ON THE THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT MIGHT BE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AND I SEE
NO ONE HERE IN OPPOSITION I'LL
LOOK AGAIN AND- ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SEEING NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE MISTER MODERATOR LET
ME ASK YOU IF THERE'S ANYONE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THE THUNDER LOW ARE
PARTICIPATING Q. LET ME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- ASSISTANCE TODAY
MISTER MODERATOR WE APPRECIATE
IT. I DIDN'T GIVE YOU MUCH TIME
TO THINK I. TO THE TO THE
COMMISSIONERS BUT LET ME LET ME
JUST ASK ANY FINAL THOUGHTS
FROM FROM THE COMMISSIONERS-
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADD
BEFORE I COME BACK TO THE
MEMBERS FOR MOTIONS AND A VOTE-
COMMISSIONER BLEW A LITTLE
ANYTHING YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADD
AS A CONCLUSION. CAN YOU HEAR
ME I'M SORRY YES WE CAN THANK
YOU. YEAH I JUST WANTED TO SAY
IT I THINK THAT- HOST HAS COME
A LONG WAY OVER MANY MANY YEARS
THAT I'VE SERVED HERE ON THE
COMMISSION I'M SO PROUD OF THE
PROGRESS THAT WE MADE. I'M
PROUD OF THE FACT THAT YOU
KNOW- THAT. WHILE WE ARE HAVE
DONE OUR BEST TO SERVE- THE
PEACE OFFICERS- TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE RECEIVING THE TOP
NOTCH TRAINING THAT THEY
DESERVE. THAT WE HAVE ALSO-
PAID ATTENTION TO AND GIVEN
SOME FOCUS TO WHAT THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS- AND YOU KNOW
AND WE'VE INFUSED A LOT A LOT
OF WHAT WE ARE WE HAVE LEARNED
THAT THEY NEED INTO NOT JUST
THE TRAINING FOR THE EXISTING
OFFICERS BUT ALSO FOR THE
INCOMING OFFICERS. TO HELP MOLD
THEM- THAT INCLUDES YOU KNOW A
LOT MORE DE ESCALATION IN MORE
DETAIL JUSTICE INFUSED IN ALL
THE TRAINING THROUGHOUT FROM
THE TOP TO THE BOTTOM AND I'M
VERY PROUD FOR THE DIRECTION
THAT POST HAS HAS TAKEN. NOT-
AND I AM. HAPPY BUT THE FACT
THAT I'VE BEEN ABLE TO BE A
PART OF THAT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- COMMISSIONER
DONLAN. YEAH YEAH JUST. JUST TO
REITERATE HOW PROUD I AM OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE ON THE
POST COMMISSION AND RETURN
SOMETHING TO A LOCATION THAT IS
RETURNED SO MUCH TO ME AND MY
FAMILY YEAH OVER MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS OF SERVICE AND
ALSO THOSE THAT I SERVE WITH.
AND YOUR QUESTION THERE'S
DEFINITELY A PUSH WELL AT THE
MOMENT AND THE POST COMMISSION
AND ITS STAFF UP TO THE
CHALLENGE JUST THIS YEAR WE
HAVE A SPECIAL MEETING TO
ADDRESS. AND WHAT'S GOING ON
THE PROFESSION. THAT INDIVIDUAL
COMMISSIONERS HERE FOR YOU
TODAY I SAW COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT HAVE ENCOURAGED-
ARRIVE RISING OF PULLS PROFILE
STATEWIDE SO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY. CAN COME TO US NOT
JUST TO OUR LOCAL AGENCY AND
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY CAN IMPACT
STANDARDS. AND FINALLY ONE OF
THE BIG ISSUES YEAH AND IN
PROTEST APPOINTMENT. AND POST
HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN ASKING
COMING UP WITH. BETTER
STANDARDS FOR POLICE AGENCIES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE AND I
THINK THAT THE FOLKS BEFORE YOU
TODAY ARE WELL AND TRULY UP TO
THE TASK. AND I AM AND I'M
PROUD TO BE BEFORE YOU AND I
APPRECIATE SB. YOUR FOXHOLE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
COMMISSIONER LONG. I WOULD GO
OF COURSE WITH GARY JUST SAID
AND WHILE I- ALSO ADD MY THANKS
TO OUR I THINK A VERY DYNAMIC
AND COLLABORATIVE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR BEING ALVAREZ'S REALLY
MEANT THE WORLD POSTED. HE'S-
HE'S ALWAYS PUSHING THE
ENVELOPE HE DEMANDS RESULTS
SINCE HE'S A COLLABORATIVE
COLLEGIAL GUY ALSO THROUGH OUR
SHARED JOY STUDLEY OF THE DA
FROM SANTA BARBARA CHOICE A
CHOICE REALLY KEEPS ON TOP OF
EVERYTHING IN. THE
COMMUNICATION BETWEENTHE
COMMISSIONERS AND POST IS
REALLY TOP NOTCH. EVEN IN THE
FIVE YEARS I'VE SERVED I'VE
SEEN GREAT IMPROVEMENT OR
EXPANSION AYE SHE SAID LIKE THE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS THAT.
THE TO DEVISE A LOT OF THE
TRAINING AND SO FORTH USED TO
BE I THINK IN MY OPINION ANYWAY.
HEAVILY ORIENTED JUST TO PISS
OFF. IT'S BROADER NOW. KING
BASED OR- ACADEMIC. SOCIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS. ARE
ACTIVELY SOUGHT JUST NOT
TOLERATED THEIR SOCKS- IS BEEN
QUITE A QUITE AN IMPROVEMENT I
POST IS REALLY GROWN. AND
CONTINUES TO GROW I DON'T WANT
TO JINX US BUT- I THINK THINGS
LOOK PRETTY GOOD AND- WE NOW.
TO KEEP THE PRESSURE ON
OURSELVES BUT WE WILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU COMMISSIONER I'M
COMMISSIONER WORK. YEAH AGAIN
JUST THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY- I'M A BIG BELIEVER
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND I
THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE WE CAN
DO TO. MARKET PROS FOR WHAT WE
DO IN THE VALUES AND COURSE
THAT WE STAND FOR IT WHETHER
IT'S YOUR OWN FORMS WITH OTHER
AGENCIES. AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES TO MEET WITH THE
COMMUNITY AN APT DISCUSSIONS IN
MEANINGFUL DIALOGUE. AND YOU
KNOW EDUCATING OURSELVES AS
WELL AS THE PUBLIC ON WHY
THINGS HAPPENED. WHAT WE CAN DO
TO IMPROVE. SO THE MORE WE
CANNOT COMMUNICATE WITH THAT.
THE STAKEHOLDERS I THINK THE
MORE FOR IT BUT THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTIONS THAT.
COMMISSIONER THANK YOU AND LAST
BUT CERTAINLY. NOT LEAST-
COMMISSIONER MERECE. WELL ADAM
I'M THE LAST ONE SO THEY TOOK
EVERYTHING SO. EVERYTHING THAT.
HAPPENS TO ME ALL THE TIME
COMMISSIONER. YEAH AND ARE YOU
KNOW I WANT TO GO BACK TO ME ON
IN THE POST OUT THERE DONE AN
AMAZING JOB YOU KNOW MANY
TAKING OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
AND IT'S REALLY DRIVEN AND VERY
PROGRESSIVE WAY. AND WE HAVE A
GREAT BOARD OF COMMISSIONERS
I'M SURE IF YOU GOT THERE ARE
MINUTES OF A MEETING YOU CAN
SEE THAT WE DON'T ALWAYS AGREE
BUT ONCE WE DO A GREAT ONCE WE
SETTLE ON SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
SUPPORTED IT SUPPORT IT AND
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN GET THERE
AND GET ACCOMPLISHED SO. YOU
HAVE A GREAT GROUP OF PEOPLE IN
FRONT OF YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY. SURE THANK
YOU. I'M GOING TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE SENATORS NOW AND DON'T
LET ME ASK DO I NEED TO
SEPARATE ANY OUT OR WE GONNA.
OKAY MR MAJORITY LEADER. YEAH
I'LL MAKE A MOTION BUT I JUST
WANTED TO ADD BECAUSE I THINK I
WAS WORKING ON THIS ISSUE MANY
DECADES AGO AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE THE
OTHER HOUSE AND- HAVE HAVE
OBSERVE WITH- GREAT- FOR THE
SUCCESSES THE COMMISSIONERS
INDICATED THE- THE GROWTH AND
MATURITY WE HAVE DEALT WITH
THIS ISSUE SO MANY TIMES THE
MCCOMB COMMISSION. THE
CHRISTOPHER COMMISSION IN MY
COMMUNITY IN LOS ANGELES. IN
DEVELOPING AND DEALING WITH THE
TENSIONS THE CHAIR TALKS ABOUT
IN IN COMMUNITY. AND IN A
RELATIONSHIP WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT HOW THAT WORKS AND
IT WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
CHALLENGING AREA AND IDEA. I
REALLY APPLAUD THE GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT AND I THINK WE
COMMISSION ALONG SAID TO.
REALLY CAPTURED IT IN TERMS OF-
COMMUNITY GROUPS BEING UP- THE-
SOUGHT AFTER INSTEAD OF
TOLERATED IS REALLY A
SIGNIFICANT SHIFT. SO WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO MANAGE YOUR
APPROPRIATE. MAKE A MOTION FOR
ALL FIVE THE COMMISSION OFF
FIVE POINTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MAJORITY LEADER AND
SEEING NO ONE ELSE TO MAKE
COMMENTS MADAM. SECRETARY WHICH
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE TURN
ON YOUR VICE. I BATES I BETTER
HERTZBERG I BURKE I LAYERED HI
THERE I WILK HI WILK AYE ATKINS
FIVE ATKINS AYE THAT IS
UNANIMOUS- COMMISSIONERS AREA
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND YOUR PATIENCE TODAY WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU DO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
HAVE A GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
SO I LET ME JUST SAY THANK YOU
TO ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY- IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFIED TODAY
THAT ONE PERSON WHO SOMEHOW
DROPPED OFF- PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS YOUR COMMENTS
AGAIN OUR AND YOUR SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THAT TESTIMONY IN OUR
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE YOUR
COOPERATION THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON MANAGER LIKE TO
MAKE ONE COMMENT FOR YOU
ADJOURNED MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN-
I THINK THIS IS A YEAH THIS IS
THIS IS MY FINAL MEETING I
THINK I'VE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE FOR ABOUT TWO AND A
HALF YEARS HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
PLEASURE AND HONOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
I ALSO SERVED AS VICE CHAIR OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I WILL TELL YOU
THIS IS. MUCH MORE
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS AND HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN A RESPECTED AND
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD AN INVOICE AND
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE. NOT
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
WITH YOU. MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
OF PLEASE FORGIVE ME I WAS
REMISS THE TIME JUST GETS AWAY
FROM US. SO LET ME CONGRATULATE
YOU ON STEP ENOUGH AS
REPUBLICAN LEADER. AND
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH YOU
PARTICULARLY AS WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF.
ESTABLISHING A WORKPLACE
CONDUCT UNIT ALL ISSUES RELATED
TO THE WORK THAT WE DO IS A
RULES COMMITTEE. AND IT JUST SO
APPRECIATE YOUR DEMEANOR YOUR
TONE AND YOUR COLLEGIALITY I
THINK I AM SUPPORTED IN THAT-
AND WITH THAT. WE WILL ADJOURN
THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR TODAY
THANK YOU EVERYONE.